a passionate goalie and a firmer
asylum-seeker michael was granted
political refuge in nottingham after
fleeing his native Zimbabwe back in 2003
his kickabout with mates were spotted by
the local teen as a community football
trust which now we found football so
important just because it it actually
brings communities together we are guys
from different countries we all have
been brought in together by Nottingham
Forest in the community Michael and his
mates are playing away to a team from
Queens Park Rangers Trust this weekend
because Amnesty International highlights
how important football can be in helping
refugees feel part of a community from
countries including Syria Sudan and
Malawi but when they're on this pitch
they're all footballers and members of
their team whether it be QPR or acting
and florists and those two clubs are
among a hundred and sixteenth taking
part in the amnesty event this weekend
triple the number of last year the visit
to West London also includes a tour of
the Loftus Road Stadium complete with
time for selfies in the dressing rooms
and to turn answering questions in the
managers chair in the press area but the
visit comes at a time when supporters
are worried that racism xenophobia is
showing an ugly side to the beautiful
game
according to Amnesty 2 in five fans
believe there's been an increase in
racism recently nearly one in four has
personally witnessed that in some way
and nine out of ten think it's the
responsibility of clubs to tackle racism
it's a big issue if people are just
calling out certain players and it's not
faired
if one person is yelling at the other
person just in this race I mean there's
still a challenge for black players
today playing so there's definitely
going to be a challenge with Asia
used to be a lot worse back in the day
20-30 years ago but people think it sort
of like and been sorted out now but it's
still underlying amnesty hopes visits
like this will not only show refugees
what people do for them but also remind
fans how much their clubs benefit from
diversity I've played in lots of
countries over the years and I you know
have played with teammates who have also
come from refugee backgrounds and I
think you know they've they're inspiring
to me because they show just what you
can achieve when you've got the right
communities and opportunities
there's an unusual honor guard flying
the flag for QPR at this season's last
home match refugees who may have fled
one homeland but hoped that here they
found a footballing family
mohnish attic Sky News